اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
بعد تدمير سنوبك خوف كسرعه تدفق مياه نهر
دنيفرو تزيد عشره اضعاف وتعقد عمليات
الانقاذ
انهيار سدنو بكخوف كي يغير معادله الحرب
وقد يعطل الهجوم المضاد من المستفيد روسيا
ام اوكرانيا
في مؤتمر محاربه داعش بن فرحان يدعو
لتجفيف
وبلينكن يحذر من خطر عودته
باسلحه ثقيله واهداف جديده حرب السودان
تاخذ بعدا اخر وانباء عن هدنه قصيره
مراقبه بالطائرات
اهلا بكم وصباح الخير بعد تدمير سنوبك خوف
كمشاهدينا لا مؤشرات على انخفاض مستوى
تاثير الكارثه بل الامر اصبح اكثر تعقيدا
فعمليات الانقاذ والاجلاء في المناطق التي
غمرها الفيضان الناجم عن تدمير السد باتت
صعبه ومعقده والسبب ان السرعه نهى الدين
يبرو الذي يقع عليه السد زادت عشره اضعاف
عمده منطقه خرسون الموالي لروسيا فلاديمير
سالدو قال ان اربعه الاف من سكان خرسون
الذين تم اجلائهم موجودون في مراكز ايواء
مؤقته وهناك اكثر منهم علقون
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء ارسلت السلطات الروسيه 45 محطه
توليد كهرباء متنقله الى المناطق المتضرره
في مقاطعه خيرسون وذلك وفق ما افاد مراسل
العربيه كما ارسلت ايضا اربعين مضخه مياه
عملاقه لسحب المياه من شوارع بعض ضواحي
المقاطعه التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
في الجنوب الاوكراني وتتهم موسكو اوكرانيا
بفتح اربعه مجال من سد يبرو بتروفيسكا
وذلك في وقت واحد لزياده اندفاع المياه من
نهر دنيبرو تجاه ضواحي خرسون معنا من
موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمه للمزيد
حول تاثير وتداعيات هذا السد كات يا اهلا
بك معنا ما المعلومات الوارده لديك تفضلي
مرحبا فاطمه بالفعل الرئيس الروسي كان قد
اوعز لطوارئ الروسيه بارسال مجموعه من
المنقذين للمساعده في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه والمواليه لروسيا
طبعا عمليات الانقاذ صعبه جدا كما تتحدث
السلطات هناك بسبب سرعه ارتفاع سرعه نهر
النيبرو نتيجه تفجير اسد طبعا كانت قد
غمرت المياه كما تحدثت السلطات هناك نحو
اربعه عشر الف منزل في نحو 35 منطقه
سكانيه تحيط او القريبه من الساده عمليات
لاجلاء مستمره تم اجلاء نحو
4300 مواطن من هنا من هناك الى مراكز
اقامه مؤقته كان هناك اجلاء لاطفال نحو
150 طفل تم اجلاؤهم وحتى الان كما تقول
السلطات المراكز الاقامه المؤقته هي قادره
ان تستوع الى نحو 5000 مواطن في حال تم
اجراءه طبعا من هذه المناطق كما تحدثت
السلطات مرارا ان طبعا تفجير السد له
عواقب ستكون وخيمه على البيئه بسبب ان
المواد المترسبه في السد تقوم بالانتقال
والتي هي تم تخزينها خلال سبعون عاما هذه
المواد السامه قد تنتقل ايضا سيكون لها
تاثير على البيئه لذلك ايضا
بتوازي مع اعمال الاجلاء هناك اعمال تخص
القضاء على هذه المواد السامه والمحاصرتها
او طبعا المساعده في عمليه او تقليل
العواقب التي ستكون نتيجه تفجير السيد
فاطمه طيب شكرا كاتي ابقي معي لانتقل الى
مراسلنا بول في مقاطعه زابوريجي رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك معنا رائد اذن زابوريجيا
يعني هي التي يدور الحديث حولها وهناك
مخاوف كثيره حولها ولكن طمئن حاكم المنطقه
باننا تداعيات نوويه من تفجير السد على
زبوريجه ولكن سؤالي رائد هل اثر تفجير
السد على تموضع القوات حول منطقه
زابوريجيا
سؤال هام جدا فاطمه لابد من تسليط الضوء
قبل الحديث عن الاوضاع العسكريه بان الجيش
الروسي قام بمضايقه فريق العربيه اثناء
تغطيه يوم امس مضايقات كبيره منعنه من
التصوير كما اسلفت في المباشره السابق وتم
ايقافنا مع الفريق باكمله دخلنا ليلا في
ساعات الحظر حظر التجوال ومن ثم نقلنا الى
المراكز الامنيه والامنيه واقضينا ليله
طويله في المراكز الامنيه حتى تم اخلاء
سبيل فريق العربيه وذلك من حساسيه المنطقه
والتطورات الحاصله حيث ان الجيش الاوكراني
ما زال يشن هجمات مضاده على اطراف
المقاطعه الحديث عن منطقه
كخوفكا
هذه هي المناطق ما زالت تتعرض لهجومات منذ
الصباح الباكر ثلاثه هجومات تقول
[موسيقى]
ذلك ما جعل المياه ترتفع مره اخرى وذلك من
اجل اغراق القوات الروسيه المتمركزه في
تلك المناطق في خرسون طبعا خرسون وزابروجي
متاخمتان فاطمه
والوضع
بالفعل ملتهب جدا هناك عمليات عسكريه
الدفاعات الجويه
تنطلق باستمرار لصد الضربات الصاروخيه
الاوكرانيه هناك اسلحه اوكرانيه حديثه
وصلت باتت تستخدم منذ دقائق وصلتنا
معلومات ان صواريخ ستار مشادو قصفت منطقه
لوغانسك ايضا في المحور الشرقي
هي تحديدا الاسلحه والصواريخ التي اتهمت
روسيا بها اوكرانيا انها ضربت السد
باستخدامها يعني كان صاروخ اولخا وبعد ذلك
تحدثوا عن هذا الصاروخ وهناك ايضا مسؤول
روسي يتحدث ليتاس الان رائد في هذا العاجل
يقول بان هناك مزرعه خمسه اشخاص من تدمير
سد نوفا كخوفك اذا الان الانباء تقول بان
هناك مسرع خمسه اشخاص بسبب تدمير هذا السد
ومقتل يعني
تضرر الكثير يعني كاتيا كانت تتحدث عن
عمليات اجلاء وعمليات انقاذ مراكز ايواء
تحتمل 5000 حتى الان من الاشخاص رائد يعني
ان عدنا للحديث عن الجانب الانساني
اذا سمحت تفضل رائد
نعم نعم نحن نحن فاطمه ما زلنا نتواصل مع
المتطوعين من ما يسمى بالجبهه الشعبيه
لانقاذ المواطنين في المسائل الانسانيه ما
زلنا متواصلين معهم وربما نكمل التغطيه
لاظهار الصوره من اعمال وزاره الطوارئ
والمتطوعين في اغاثه اللاجئين اليوم نحن
ما زلنا نتواصل من اجل تسليط الضوء على
هذا الجانب بالفعل الوضع كارثي المياه
غمرت المنطقه باكملها البيوت وحتى قرى
باكملها كانت مغموره هناك عالقين هناك
مفقودين وهناك يعني قتل حقيقه بالامس
تكلمنا عن ان المياه غمرت مقبره واصبحت
الجثث باتت تطفو فوق هذه
المقبره كثير من
المسائل الانسانيه
ربما تكون صعبه عند القاط في تلك المنطقه
خاصه لانها منطقه تماس ومنطقه عسكريه
والحواجز الامنيه التي تحيط بتلك المنطقه
ليست نوفا خوفك وحده وانما معظم القرى على
اطراف خرسون اريد ان اشير الى الخنادق
الروسيه التي بدات من اجل هي خطط دفاعيه
من اجل عدم تكرار ما حصل في لمان وما حصل
في خرسون لان مدينه خرسون هي مع الجانب
الاوكراني مقاطعه خرسون باكملها او
المتبقي منها مع جانب الروسي ونهر دينيبرو
يفصل القوات الروسيه عن القوات الاوكرانيه
على الضفه الشماليه القوات الروسيه وعلى
الضفه الجنوبيه القوات الاوكرانيه القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تحاول يوميا عبور هذا
النار نهر نرى خلفي كثافه مرور المركبات
العسكريه
وتنقلاتها باستمرار لا يتوقف هذا
مرور القوات الاوكرانيه الى الجانب
الشمالي من النهر ولكن اسمح لي ان اعود
الى كاتيا لاسالها هنا تحديدا يعني كاتيا
كيف تتداول الانباء الروسيه هذا التفجير
يعني هل بالفعل تاثر تقدم القوات الروسيه
هل بالفعل استطاعت بان يعني اوكرانيا بما
ان روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا بتفجير السد هل
تمكنت اوكرانيا من تعطيل التقدم الروسي
على الارض
بالفعل فاطمه ما يتم تداوله على مستوى
المسؤولين الرؤوس بان هذه العمليه هي
محاوله محاوله من الجانب الاوكراني لانشاء
دفاع من الجانب الايسر لنهر نيبرو وذلك من
اجل التوجه نحو عمليات الهجوم في منطقه
دونات كما كنا شاهدنا خلال الايام السابقه
كان هناك هجوم مضاد كما تحدثت الدفاع
الروسيه على مدى يومين متتاليين وبالتالي
كما تقول روسيا هناك طبعا بالتاكيد كانت
محاوله لايقاف القوات الروسيه وانشاء خط
دفاع في هذه المنطقه التي طبعا تم تفجير
فيها ولكن طبعا نحن كما نشاهد ومن خلال
كما تحدث بعض الخبراء العسكريين ان بالفعل
هو هذه العمليه تفجير السد هي ليست مجديه
للطرفين لانها الان هي تؤدي الى عواقب
كبيره على الناحيه الانسانيه وسواء كانت
على الناحيه البيئيه بعد تفجير السد هناك
طبعا سيكون معاناه كبيره للمواطنين الذين
هم كانوا قاتنين في هذه المنطقه سواء كان
من الجانب الاوكراني او من الجانب التي
تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه فاطمه نعم وهذه
تحديدا النقاط التي سنتحدث فيها مع ضيوفنا
في هذه النشره كاتيا من المستفيد الاكبر
من تفجير اسد شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
مراسله العربيه
رائد الاغبر
ما بين شرق روسي وغرب اوكراني نهر يفصل
بينهما وسد غير مجرى المعارك انهيار سنوبك
خوف كالواقع على نهر دينيبرو لكن السؤال
الابرز من المستفيد الاكبر في هذه الحاله
لنبدا من الجانب الروسي الذي نفى ان يكون
له يد في ذلك كيف له ان يؤلم نفسه بنفسه
اولا انهيار سد نوفاك خوفك يعني ان المياه
ستتدفق من مجرى مع مجرى النهر اي باتجاه
الشرق الذي تتمركز فيه القوات الروسيه
وتشم ضرباتها منه وبالتالي ستضطر القوات
الروسيه لاجلاء قواتها وسكانها بعيدا عن
خيرسون احد اسخر النقاط الاستراتيجيه في
الحرب اما ثانيا فلما قد تقطع روسيا
امدادات المياه لشبه جزيره القرد التي
ترتوي من ذلك السد
[موسيقى]
الا اجابه وافيه ولكن بالنظر الى تاريخ
الدب الروسي نفت القوات السوفي او نسفت
القوات السوفيتيه انذاك سدا على دينيبرو
ايضا منذ نحو قرن واضحت بالالاف مقابل عدم
تقدم النازيين اما اوكرانيا المنصبه على
التخطيط لهجومها المضاد يبدو انها رات ان
لا سبيل لذلك سوى ان تكسر القبضه الروسيه
الخانقه على مساحه واسعه من اراضيها بمعنى
اخر وان كانت اصبحت الضفه الشرقيه منطقه
محظوره على الدروع الاوكرانيه الا انها
حتى وقبل تفجير السد كانت عمليه محفوفه
بالمخاطر وتتطلب تكتيكات برمائيه للعبور
من موسكو معنا المحلل العسكري الروسي بفيل
في الجنهار ومن كيف الدبلوماسيه والمستشار
السابق فلاديمير اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام
ابدا معك سيد بافل يعني الروس يتهمون
الاوكران بانهم يعني هم من فجروا هذا السد
برايك هل يمكن
لروسيا ان تطلق الرصاص على قدمها فقط
لتمنع التقدم الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
بعضه مع البعض كما ان هنالك بعض الخبراء
الذين يقولون بانه ربما حصل فيضان وتدفق
اضافي لان المخزون زاد عن حده بسبب مياه
هيئه الربيع
ولم يتم
انزاله الى النهر الى الان ليس واضحا ما
الذي قام بالعمليه ولكن اجراءات طبيعيه
خلال اوقات الحرب
ان تستخدم هذه
المياه مثلا
لتفريغها لمن العدو من اجتياز المناطق حسب
ذلك عده مرات في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بسدود اصغر
نعم مثل هذه الامور تحصل بين الحين والاخر
وبعض المسؤولين عن روسيا يقولون بان هذا
يعطي لروسيا الافريقيه لانه يمنع
الاوكرانيين من اجتياز النهر النيترا
[موسيقى]
وهذا ايضا سيؤثر على الجيش الروسي
بالمقابل لان الدفاعاتهم مكانه على
الجانب اليسار من نهر
للانسحاب بكل سرعه
وفقدوا الكثير من المعدات وربما حاطتها
بعض الارواح كالعمليه الاجلاء السريعه
الانسحاب لم يكن معظمه بشكل جيد اذا كلا
الجانبين عنيه بسبب ما حصل طيب ابقى معي
سيد بلقنهاور انتقل الى السيد يعني روسيا
تنفي انها
ولكن ايضا الجانب الاوكراني مستفيد بشكل
كبير من التفجير يعني ادى قسمت المنطقه
وعزلت جزيره القرم وهو هدف اساسي بالنسبه
للاوكران فانها بذلك تستطيع ان تستعيد
اراضيها بسهوله بالتالي ما رايك وتعليقك
على هذا على هذه النقطه تحديدا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته تحيه
طيبه من اوكرانيا نحن الان نشاهد
الاوكرانيا وكل العالم
بان هذا جماعيه ضد شعب الاوكراني
واوكرانيا تدعموكرانيا اكيد هذا هورا
لنتذكر
قبل التراجع من هذا المنطقه جيش اوكرانيا
لم يدمر هذا السطر جيشه اوكراني لم يدمر
هذا الجسور عبر المهرنيبرو ولكن كان في
صالح اوكرانيا تدمير هذا منذ سنه واربع
وجهه
ليوقف هجوم الروس على هذا المنطقه ولكن
اوكرانيا اللي عم يعمل هذا لان كل هذه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكن الان نحن نشاهد
في انقله هجوم مضاد المتوقع روسيا تدمرت
هذا
هجوم مضاد قوات مصالحه اوكرانيا كل
تصريحات روسيه
تدمير هذا
روسيا هذا هورا سبيل حول تمديدات مياح
امتداد المياه الى شبه الجزيره اوكرانيا
دمرت هذا الصدر او هي وقفت امدادات المياه
الى شبه جزيره في سنه 2014 يعني لمده
ثمانيه سنوات شبه جزيره القرمشه بدون مياه
النيبره ولم تكن هناك الكارثه
الان كل مخازن وحوضات في شبه المختلف
مليانه بالمياه بالمياه الداخل موجود
انهار محليه وبحريرات يعني لم تكون اي
كارثه في اقرب سنه اذا لم تكون هناك لمياه
من نهر النيبرو ولكن اكيد نعم ابقى معي
سيد في اعود اليك لماذا قد تقدم
اوكرانيا على تفجير هذا السد في ظل جميع
النقاط التي ذكرها سيد شوماكوب يعني القرم
برايه لن يتاثر بهذا التفجير القوات
الاوكرانيه هي المتضرره الاكبر من هذا
التفجير اعاقه الهجوم المضاده ايضا بسب ب
هذا التفجير بالتالي برايه الجانب الروسي
هو المستفيد الاكبر منه فكيف يستفيد
الجانب الروسي من هذا التفجير وانا اتحدث
عسكريا سيد
كما قلت تلك الى الجانبين اتهموا الاخر
وكلاهما معنا من الخسائر
بهذه الكارثه ذلك عسكريا
وبالتاكيد السكان المدنيين دفعوا ثمنا
كبيرا
لو كانت لاوكرانيا خطط لاجتياز شهريا
وتجاوز الدفاعات الروسيه فيروشيا فمثل هذه
الخطط سوف تتوقف على الاقل الوقت الراهن
هنالك تغيير في الخطط وعلى رؤوس ايضا
الطرق لسحب دفاعاتهم من نهر النيبروت
وربما تكون هنالك عواق اخرى
فلو الروس ثم قابل ذلك
فيمكن ان تتعامل روسيا مع هذا الموقف
انسحبوا من نهر
وحاولوا دفاعات جديده في منطقه الخرسون
وهذا
يعني قدرتهم على الانتقال من هذه الزاويه
والاوكرانيين يتمكنوا من المهاجمه وربما
هذا منطقي بعض الشيء
طيب ولكن في تصريحات سابقه له خرج وقال
انه يجب علينا منع الهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني وردعه ثم سنقوم بهجوم من جانبنا
نحن يعني هي ليست عمليه عسكريه بعد الان
وانما هجوم مضاد روسي في المقابل
هكذا هي الخطه نعم
لردعي ومنعي هذا الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
وبالتالي القوات الروسيه التي ستهاجم بعد
ذلك هذه الخطه الان واعملوا لنا انهم
قادرون على وقفي الهجوم الاوكراني
كانت هناك بعض التقارير التي افادت بانهم
قاموا بردع القوات الاوكرانيه من شان هذه
الهجمات الاوليه ولكن يبدو ان هذه الهجمات
لم تحصل في اي وقت قريب القتال سيكون هناك
تصعيد وتصعيد جدي من كلا الجانبين
طيب اعود اليك سيدي شوماكوب بعد هذا
الموقف وتفجير السد واتهامات اوكرانيا
لروسيا بذلك كيف يمكن ان تكون رده فعل
اوكرانيا فيما يخص الهجوم المضاد يعني هل
ربما سنرى تغيير في التكتيكات
والاستراتيجيه هل ربما سنرى تراجع في
استراتيجيه الهجوم المضاد نعم لو سمحت اذا
ممكن ملاحظه حول هذا الصاد ان اتخاذ
السوفياتي صمم هذا الصدر يعني
صواريخ وقنابل يعني من المستحيل لتدمير
هذا البنيه تحقيق هائله بالضربه الصاروخيه
اكيد كان انفجار من داخل وروسيا هي تسيطر
الان بهذا السابق اولا ثانيا لنرى نتيجه
هذا هذا الان موجود تهديدات
تحديدا يمكن القول ويمكن استخدام ذريعه
خطوط الدفاعيه تروسيه فيها المنطقه نعم
موجود الفيدان والغمره الخط الاول الروسي
على الشوا ولكن روسيا حشدت عدد الضخم
قواتها بعيده من الشواطئ الشرقيه في عمقها
ضيفه موجود الخطوط رقم اثنين خطوط رقم 3
يعني بصفه عمل لن تكون ادرار هاي للجيش
روسيا نعمل هذا التفجير سوف يعرقل هجوم
مضاد قوات مصالح اوكرانيا ولكن كما افاد
سيد رئيس اوكرانيا بصفه عامه هذا لن يتغير
مسار حرب بصراحه الان عبور هذا المنطقه
هذا هذا الماهر النيبروس ويجيد لقوات
مصالحه اوكرانيا لان موجود توسيع الى هذا
الظاهر علاوه هذا عندنا شواغل بان هذا
التفجير الصوف
طفى
المنطقه لان هذه هذا الفدان وهو الدمر
مقابر في هذا المنطقه وكمان مقابر
الجنود وعلى السطح الان نحن نشاهد جيوف
الروس كمان عندنا الموت السمك الكبير في
هذا يعني
بصفه عامه هذا الكارثه هائله
الاجلاء من مناطق جولا بريس تحت سيطره
روسيه من مناطق نوفا من منطقه
الان عندما موجود عمليه الاجلاء سكان
منطقه اثيرسون روسيا طقس في مدينه خرسون
بشكل عنيف وتعرقل عمليه
تبدا القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم في باخ مود
حقيقه وتستغل هذه الازمه بحسب بعض
من التقارير شكرا جزيلا لك من كييف
الدبلوماسيه والمستشار السابق فلاديمير
وشوماكوف ومن موسكو المحلل العسكري الروسي
بافيل في
نبقى في تداعيات انهيار سدنوبك خوف
كمشاهدينا فقد اوضح حاكم منطقه زابوريجيا
ان وضع محطه الطاقه النوويه مستقر حاليا
رغم الاضرار التي طالت السد الذي يعمل على
تبريد المحطه مؤكدا وبعد اجراء تدريبات
طارئه على كارثه نوويه مستوى المياه طبيعي
في بركه التبريد ويبلغ حتى الان 16.6 متر
مشيرا الى ان بعض المواد الخامله او بعض
المولدات خامله والاخر منها يخضع الى
الاصلاح
ان مستويات الاشعاع داخل وحول المصنع ضمن
النطاق الطبيعي وفي ظل تفاقم الاضرار
الناجمه عن الكارثه نجد الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديميرازيلنسكي منظمات الاغاثه الدوليه
باتخاذ اجراءات فوريه لمواجهه تداعيات
تدمير السد الذي يستخدم في توليد الطاقه
الكهرومائيه في البلاد كما اعتبر زيلينسكي
ان اي منظمه لا تقدم المساعده في منطقه
الكارثه انها ببساطه لا تتمتع بالكفاءه
مطالبا المنظمات الدوليه مثل اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر مثلا بالشروع في
عمليه الانقاذ ومساعده الناس على الفور
وكان قد اعلن زيلينسكي انه اجرى زياره عمل
الى خرسون لمتابعه الاضرار الناجمه عن
تدمير السد
وقال ايضا انه بحث اجراءات التصدي للكارثه
واجلاء السكان من مناطق الفيضانات
المحتمله وايضا سبل استعاده النظام البيئي
في المنطقه اضافه الى الوضع العسكري
العملياتي لقوته
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها
بكين تستفز تايوان عشرات المقاتلات
الصينيه تخترق الجزيره
احييكم من جديد في الاجتماع الوزاري
للتحالف الدولي لمحاربه داعش والمنعقد في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بحضور وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
ركز المسؤولون على اهميه تجفيف منابع
تمويل التنظيم الارهابي وحذروا من عودته
المباغته وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان اكد التزام المملكه على ضروره
مكافحه الارهاب والتصدي للفكر المتطرف
وقال ان المملكه ستبذل كل جهد لملاحقه
تنظيم داعش وفكره اينما كان
فان السبيل الى الامن والاستقرار والتنميه
والازدهار يتطلب استمرار جهودنا الجماعيه
في محاربه الارهاب وجماعاته المجرمه
ومواجهه الفكر المتطرف الذي يتناقض مع كل
القيم الدينيه والانسانيه والاخلاقيه
وستستمر بالعديد في بدل كل جهد ممكن
معكم جميعا في سبيل دعم جهود التحالف
الدولي ضد تنظيم داعش والقضاء على جميع
انشطته وامتداداته الاجراميه اينما كانت
ومواجهه محاولاتها الشيطانيه في استغلال
وتجنيد الاطفال والشباب وتجفيف في مصادر
التمويله ودعمه
بجانبه دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى
تسريع عمليه استعاده مسلحي داعش الاجانب
من المخيمات السوريه وحذر خلال افتتاح
الاجتماع الوزاري للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش
حذر من بقاء مقاتل داعش الاجانب في
المخيمات حيث انه يهدد بعوده التنظيم من
جديد
تعتبر اعاده المقاتلين الارهابيين الاجانب
وافراد عائلاتهم الى اوطانهم امرا بالغ
الاهميه لتقليل عدد سكان مخيمات النازحين
مثل الهول ومراكز الاحتجاز التي تضم ما
يقرب من عشره الاف مقاتل 2000 منهم من دول
اخرى غير سوريا والعراق ان الفشل في اعاده
المقاتلين الاجانب الى اوطانهم يزيد مخاطر
حملهم السلاح مره اخرى ومحاوله استعاده ما
يسمى بخلافه داعش وايضا ترهيب المجتمعات
التي نعمل على استقرارها واعاده بنائها
وكذلك احتمال تهديد اوطادنا
انضم الينا من القاهره الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه ماهر فرغلي اهلا بك
معنا سيد ماهر اذا يعني في هذا المؤتمر
المهم شدد المسؤولون على اهميه تجفيف
منابع تمويه تنظيم الارهابي ما سبل تجفيف
هذا التنظيم برايك
بعد التحيه طبعا هذا المؤتمر مهم للغايه
والسعوديه دائما تكرره في عام 2017 وعام
2020 22 السعوديه دائما تقوم باستضافه هذا
المؤتمر المهم جدا للتحالف الدولي الذي
يضم العديد من الدول
الاهميه تنبع من ان مسارات مكافحه التطرف
العنيف يعني او او الارهاب بمعنى ادق لان
التطرف له مستويات متعدده تنبع من ثلاثه
محاور مهمه او ثلاثه مسارات يعني المسار
الاول هو مسار مكافحه الافكار التي تؤدي
الى الارهاب والتطرف والمسار الثاني مسار
تفكيك التنظيمات المتطرفه
تفكيكا بالمواجهات الامنيه والمسار الثالث
هو المسار العلاجي او الاستيعابي او
الاحتواء او البرامج العلاجيه
للمتطرفين والارهابيين على بين هذه
المسارات الثلاثه يكون التمويل وتكون
اقامه وكيفيه تفكيكها والبرامج
المتنوعه بين الدول وكل دوله لها تجربه
خاصه ومنها مثلا عشان المثال التجربه
الاماراتيه تجربه مهمه جدا في مكافحه
تنظيمات الارهابيه في دول العالم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتجربه المناصحه التجربه
المصريه في مبادرات وتصحيح المفاهيم
للارهابيين
من داعش في المعاقل والمخيمات في سوريا
كما ذكر كيف يمكن تجفيف مخاطرهم ومنعهم من
العوده على المشهد من جديد
للاسف هناك مشكلات حقيقيه او اشكاليات
تتعلق بهذه المساله تحديدا واحد هو
انتقالي الارهابين الى اماكن اخرى بها
توتر
وقاعده يعني مهمه جدا وهي ان هذه
التنظيمات تتواجد في اماكن التوتر والقلق
السياسي والاضطراب هذه النقطه الاولى
الانتقال الى اماكن الموانئ والبحار
تحديدا يعني ما يطلقون عليه الجهاد البحري
والحصول على التمويلات والحصول في اماكن
التوتر ونقل الاسلحه والرهائن وغيرها يعني
اصبحت من اليسر والسهوله مثلا في قاره مثل
قاره افريقيا
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه تتعلق بان
هذه التنظيمات او بعض المساجين
والمعتقلين او الموجودين في المخيمات
لديهم مشكلات تتعلق بالقانون الدولي
والقوانين بعض الدول في كيفيه عودتهم يعني
هل كيف يعودون وهل سيحاكمون ام لا ومن
الذي سيحاكمهم هل يحاكمون في في اماكن
احتجاز لم يحاكمون في دولهم الاساسيه
وهناك بعض الدول ترفض استقبال هؤلاء
المقاتلين خوفا منهم او خوفا من عمل مشكله
اخرى اضافه الى الجيل الذي ولد بين حوالي
اكثر من عشره الاف مثلا في مخيم الهول
لاطفال ونساء وهذا الجيل كبر على التوتر
وكبر على الخوف وكبر على الارهاب فهذه
مشكله حقيقيه لبعض الدول طيب شكرا جزيلا
لك الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه ماهر
فرغلي
مستمرون معكم ونتابع
كيف انها كندا تحترق ونيويورك تختنق
بعد تدمير تدنوبك خوف كسرعه تدفق مياه نهر
دنيبرو تزيد عشره اضعاف وتعقد عمليات
الانقاذ
انهياره
معادله الحرب وقد يعطل الهجوم المضاد من
المستفيد روسيا ام اوكرانيا
في محاربه داعش بن فرحان يدعو لتجفيف
منابع للتنظيم
يحذر من خطر عودته
باسلحه ثقيله واهداف جديده حرب السودان
تاخذ بعدا اخر وانباء عن هدنه قصيره
مراقبه بالطائرات
احييكم من جديد اخذت المعارك مشاهدينا في
السودان بعدا اخر بعد دخولها على خط
السفارات والبعثات الدبلوماسيه وفي تطور
لافت ايضا احتدم القتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وذلك للسيطره
على مستودعات الوقود والاسلحه وهذا بدا
واضحا من المعارك التي اندلعت حول مجمع
اليرموك للاسلحه التابعه للجيش في جنوب
الخرطوم وامتداده على محيط مستودعات
الوقود والغاز في المنطقه مما يمطر بخطر
انفجارها تصاعد وتيره العنف المدن الثلاث
الخرطوم بحري وام درمان دفع الى الحاجه
الملحه لهدنه عاجله تمنح الدعم الانساني
للسودانيين ولو لبرهه قليله
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذه المقاطع التي تظهر توجه
عشرات العربات المدرعه التابعه للجيش
السوداني نحو مستودعات الشجره ومجمع
اليرموك الصناعي العسكري في جنوب الخرطوم
وذلك بعد السيطره عليه واستعادته من يد
القوات التابعه للدعم السريع
[تصفيق]
وعلى الرغم من تعقيد المحادثات محادثات
هدنه السودان طبعا فان الوسطاء الراعين
لتلك المفاوضات بين ممثلين عن الجيش
والدعم السريع ماضون في حث الطرفين على
وقف النار فقد اوضح مسؤول من الدعم السريع
ان طرفي الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه
سيقدمان او يقدمان مقترحا بهدنه لمده لمده
24 ساعه المقترح يتضمن فرض عقوبات على
الطرف الذي سيخرق الهدنه كما سيتم تعليق
المفاوضات نهائيا في حال لم يلتزم بها
الجانبان وذلك بحسب مسؤول مراقبه هذه
الهدنه القصيره ستتم من قبل الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه عن طريق طائرات
للمراقبه واذا ما تطرقنا للوضع الانساني
في السودان بسبب القتال فهناك ازمه خطيره
تتفاقم في اخر معلومات حول الوضع اعلنت
الامم المتحده عن اخلاء دار ايتام سودانيه
بعد وفاه اكثر من 70 طفلا وسط القتال
المستمر
بعد يوم على وفاه اطفال رضع داخل
المستشفيات بسبب نقص الامدادات بينما
توقفت اغلب المستشفيات في الخرطوم منذ
ايام عن العمل بسبب الاشتباكات معنا من
القاهره الكاتب الصحفي السوداني حمور
زياده اهلا بك معنا سيد حمور يعني الوضع
كارثي في السودان ان كان الوضع العسكري
الميداني العسكري الانساني كذلك ولكن
لنبدا بالحديث عن المعارك التي تاخذ بعدا
اخر والتي تستمر في التصعيد الان في
استهداف لمخازن الاسلحه في استهداف لاماكن
تخزين الوقود يعني ما مدى خطوره ذلك
ولماذا نرى هذا التصعيد من الجانبين
طبعا هناك خطوره انسانيه في ان يعني هذه
المستودعات بها اغلب احتياجات البلاد من
الوقود ومن الغاز
وللاسف طبعا توزيعها متعثر في خلال
الشهرين الماضيين بسبب الحرب لكن وجودها
في حد ذاته هو كان يمثل نوع من الطمانينه
انه بمجرد ان تستقر الاوضاع او يحصل
الهدوء بالتزام بهدنه يمكن ان يتم توزيع
وتوفير هذه المخزونات للمواطنين المحتاجين
في العاصمه وفي الولايات الاخرى لكن الان
ان تصبح هذه المستودعات يعني مسرحا
للعمليات الحربيه هذا امر يثير القلق يعني
حول سلامه هذه المخزونات اضافه الى سلامه
المواطنين الذين يسكنون بالقرب منها لانها
معرضه الان للقصف من الطيران او حتى
التخريب من الدعم السريع مما يعني ان
تتحول هذه المناطق كلها الى قنبله مشتعله
على مستوى اخر يعني يبدو واضحا طبعا انهم
الطرفين لا يريدان الالتزام باي هدنه سبق
ان وقع عليها الحديث عن هدنه قادمه فيما
اعلم انه ربما يتم التوقيع عليها غدا
لكن انا لا اتوقع اي التزام كل طرف
يعني بخصوص هذه الهدنه لمده 24 ساعه يعني
لالتقاط الانفاس ولكن لا يبدو ان الطرفان
ياخذون الامر بجديه كما كان يقول يعني
الوسطاء السعوديين والسعوديين والامريكان
بان الجانبان والطرفان لا ياخذون موضوع
الهدنه بجديه ونرى ذلك الان في التصعيد
واستهداف مخازن الاسلحه واماكن الوقود
يعني ماذا ستفيد هذه الهدنه برايك
هذا حقيقي هم لا ياخذان الامر بجديه هم
فقط لا يريدان ان يفسد علاقتهما
اعتذر عن المقاطعه ولكن يبدو ان لدينا خبر
عاجل ومهم وصور مهمه ومباشره للرئيس
الاوكرانيه فلاديمير وهو يزور ويتفقد
منطقه من المناطق المتضرره في خرسون
تحديدا عند سد نوفيكا الذي تم تفجيره منذ
ايام الطرفان يتبادلان الالتهامات كما
نعلم الجانب الاوكرانيه يتهم الجانب
الروسي
والروس يتهمون الاوكران عدد كبير من
المسؤولين الاوكران يرافقان الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي كما نرى
امامنا على الشاشه وهو يتحدث اليهم
ويبدو ان هنا هذه المناطق المتضرره
بالفيضان ونرى
الاشخاص يتجمعون ويتحدثون من حول الرئيس
الاوكراني قوارب اغاثه
نشاهدها ايضا كذلك ومن هذه المنطقه التي
يتحدث بها زلنسكي قال انه بحث اجراءات
التصدي للكارثه واجلاء السكان من مناطق
الفيضانات المحتمله وسبل استعاده النظام
البيئي في المنطقه واضاف ايضا بان الوضع
العسكري العملياتي في اوكرانيا مستمر وعلى
ما يبدو الهجوم المضاد كذلك كما تحدثنا مع
المحللين ايضا مستمره
يزور مناطق الفيضانات الناجمه عن تدمير
سبك نوفاك خوفك في خرسون
طبعا شكرا جزيلا لضيفي من القاهره الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني حمور زياد الانضمامه معنا
ونعود الى سياق نشرتنا حيث افادت وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه في بيان نشرته على
حسابها في تويتر عن دخول 37 طائره تابعه
للجيش الصيني لجيش التحرير الشعب الصيني
دخلت المجال الجوي لجنوب غرب التايوان
بالاضافه الى عده طائرات في منطقه غرب
المحيط الهادئ عبر المجال الجوي وذلك
لاجراء تدريبات استطلاع جوي بعيده المدى
واوضحت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان القوات
المسلحه التايوانيه تراقب الوضع عن كثب من
خلال انظمه المراقبه والاستطلاع مؤكده
انها قد نشرت دوريات جويه قتاليه وسفن
حربيه وانظمه صواريخ ارضيه ردا على تصرفات
بكين هذا ورفضت الخارجيه الصينيه تعليقات
يابانيه ابدت مخاوف من المناورات الجويه
الصينيه الروسيه المشتركه في بحر الصين
وقال متحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان هذه
المناورات تتم وفقا للقانون الدولي ولا
تستهدف اي دوله
حرائق مستعره تلهب الانحاء الكنديه
وبالاخص جنوبها حيث الغابات المتراميه في
اطرافها مئات من السنه اللهب تلتهم مساحات
شاسعه الوضع خرج عن السيطره وكل الفرق
تكافح لاخمادها جوا بالطائرات وبرا برجال
الاطفاء السلطات الكنديه اكدت ان اكثر من
تسعه ملايين فدان قد احترقت بالفعل وذلك
اثرا اندلاعي اكثر من 400 حريق نصفها تحت
تصنيف لا قوه تخمدها سريعا المشهد كارثي
هنا حيث الغابات رئه الارض انها تختنق
والاشد تضررا من اللدغات الناريه تلك
اقليم كيبيك الشرقي الكبير الذي بات يعاني
من تداعيات على بنيته التحتيه كاغلاق
الطرق والقطاع التيار الكهربائي
[موسيقى]
كندا تشتعل المشاهدين نارها تقلب الاجواء
ذعر وخوف لم تكن تداعيات الحرائق بعيده عن
الجاره حيث ضفاف بحيره
اونتاريو كما تشاهدون سماء نيويورك محمومه
كالجمر فالنيران في كندا ودخانها يخرج عن
الحدود مقتحما تلك المدينه التي تصدرت
قائمه الاسوا في تلوث الهواء في العالم
البيت الابيض وصف الحاله بالمدمره
والتاريخيه وعليه بدر الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بعرض المسانده وخلال مكالمه هاتفيه
مع رئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن اكد انه
مستعد لتوفير كل القدرات الفيدراليه
المخصصه لمكافحه الحرائق والتي يمكن ان
تساعد بسرعه في اخماد الحرائق التي تؤثر
على المجتمعات الكنديه والامريكيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ثار بركان كيلويا وهو احد انشط البراكين
على كوكب الارض حسبما قالت هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه وتظهر صور شقوقا في
قلب البركان الذي ينشط من حين لاخر مع
تدفق كتل من الحمم البركانيه
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
بعد تدمير سد النبك خوفك كسرعه تدفق مياه
نهر دنيبرو تزيد عشره اضعاف وتعقد عمليات
الانقاذ
انهيار تدنوبك اخوفك يغير معادله الحرب
وقد يعطل الهجوم المضاد من المستفيد روسيا
ام اوكرانيا
في امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات